[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covin 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été acceptez vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui cette des
représentants des organisations
représentatives des médecins libéraux
qui estiment avoir été exclu de la
stratégie globale de lutte contre
l'épidémie
voici tout de suite la table ronde qui
les a réunis mesdames messieurs chers
collègues nous poursuivons les travaux
de la mission avec une table ronde
aujourd'hui réunies sont les
représentants d'organisations de
médecins libéraux pour ouvrir cette
réunion j'ai envie de dire que nous
sommes en face d'un paradoxe la médecine
de ville a été fortement sollicité pour
la prise en charge des patients atteints
du coc vie de 19 notamment dans ses
formes les plus bénignes selon les
chiffres de santé publique france le
nombre de patients ayant consulté un
médecin généraliste pour un cadre kobe
19 et est estimé à 4 à près de 95 milles
au cours de la dernière semaine de mars
avant il est vrai de fortement décroître
au cours des deux semaines suivantes
c'est au cours de cette même semaine que
le nombre d'actes sos médecins pour
suspicion de kobe 19 a également atteint
un pic
les médecins de ville ont aussi continué
à prendre en charge leurs patients
notamment au moyen de la
téléconsultation palliant les craintes
des patients de se rendre et cabinets
médicaux ont également été mises en
place des centres de consultation
obligatoire pour ceux présentant des
symptômes du commis de 19 pour autant la
place des médecins de ville dans le
dispositif d'urgence est encore discutée
certains regrettent de ne pas avoir été
suffisamment associés est intégré dans
la réponse avec les sanitaires
jugé trop centrée sur les établissements
de santé exposés au virus dans le cadre
leur consultation les médecins libéraux
ont aussi dénoncé le fait de ne pas
avoir eu les moyens de se protéger avec
des masques et des sur blood and ne pas
avoir eu accès aux tests dépistage
autant de sujets que nous allons aborder
ensemble pour démarrer cette audition je
vous demande et d'en produire 2
l'audition par un petit propos liminaire
chacun vous êtes relativement nombreux
dont je vous demanderai de tenir sur
environ 2 à 3 minutes sur le propos
liminaire ensuite on enchaînera par les
échanges
alors on peut peut-être commencer comme
ça dans l'ordre si ça vous dérange pas
merci merci monsieur le vice président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs pour les médecins libéraux
pour la confédération des syndicats
médicaux français que je représente
cette crise du coc vie 19 a été un
moment extrêmement difficile pour la
médecine libérale qui a été marqué par
une gestion de la pénurie et une grande
défaillance et ses résultats la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français avait mis en place dès le 15
mars une s'il de crise qui s'est réuni
tous les jours avec un bureau confédéral
qui s'est réuni deux fois par semaine
bien sûr par visioconférence pendant
toute cette durée
nous avons donc une traçabilité absolue
tout ce qui s'est passé j'ai toutes mes
notes ici qu'ils peuvent en attester
je commencerai par une première réunion
en avait une autre trois semaines avant
de la direction générale de la santé où
mes confrères étaient également présents
ou jérôme salle au mans nous a dit que
effectivement il n'y avait pas de stocks
stratégiques a fait 2 et qu' ils
organisaient les protections et que nous
aurions des boîtes de 50 masques par
professionnels de santé
c'était le 2 mars déjà le 26 février
et c'est facile à retrouver sur notre
site internet
la csmf envoyer un communiqué de presse
demandant à ce que l'état protège les
médecins libéraux par masque sur blues
et tous les équipements de protection
individuelle nous avons renouvelé nos
demandes par communiqué de presse le 6
mars
l'éditorial qui est paru le 15 mars dans
notre revue le 16 mars les médecins
spécialistes le 23 mars les médecins
spécialistes en communiqué de presse
nous avons pu faire un point journaliers
en particulier sur les masques
et nous avons pu constater au fur et à
mesure qu'il y avait des manques de
distribution de masques contrairement à
ce que nous avions comme élément
d'information de la part du cabinet que
j'appelais pratiquement tous les jours
en particulier michael benzaki le
conseiller technique et nicolas revel
nous avons rencontré le 12 mars
olivier vers ans accompagnés 12 mars
olivier reverrons recevait la csmf et
très curieusement il était accompagné
bien sûr de son directeur de cabinet
raymond lemoine de nicolas revel et de
cécile courrèges
c'était donc une audience extrêmement
renforcé dans son format et là on nous
assurer qu effectivement nous aurions
olivier verrons-nous dits ffp2 on va en
avoir et les masques chirurgicaux vous
en aurez trois par jour et sur la durée
du notaire je lui ai posé la question la
ffp 2 pour qui pour tous les médecins
je vous rappelle qu'à l'époque il était
réservé à ceux qui en cubes et qui
faisait des gestes dans la sphère
oropharyngée mais pas en ville comment
pouvait travailler non seulement les
chirurgiens dentistes mais les url ou
autre dans ces conditions
nous avons donc suivi cela tout le long
et nous avons pu constater au fur et à
mesure de nos points téléphonique
journalier que les problèmes de masques
ont perduré y compris jusqu'à fin mars
et début avril ou encore dans une
réunion intersyndicale de 2 avril entre
le cnps la ff ps nous remonter des
manques de masques sur le terrain alors
que le cabinet nous disaient tous les
jours mais si si son parti on les a
débloqué 50 millions ça passe par les
pharmacies etc
j'ai moi même pu aller chercher des
masques toutes les semaines on va
pharmacie une semaine sur deux il n'y
avait pas de masque on n'avait pas reçu
on les a ils arriveront demain
voilà quelle a été la vraie situation
d'après mes notes personnelles
on peut dire que nous n'avions plus de
problèmes sur les masques à partir
grosso modo du 6 10 avril
je vous rappelle que ça faisait bien
longtemps que malheureusement nous
avions payé un lourd tribut à cette
terrible épidémie avec des médecins qui
sont morts au combat
une trentaine et cinq à six mines qui se
sont arrêtés deuxième pénurie des tests
les tests ont manqué tout le long de
cette épidémie pour la médecine libérale
et nous n'avons pu obtenir des tests
dans les laboratoires privés que dans
les tous derniers jours de mars 2 mars
j'ai dû moi-même intervenir dans mon
département parce que nous n'avions
aucun accès aux tests grâce à mon carnet
d adresses auprès du directeur de la rs
pour qu'ils donnent une dérogation aux
laboratoires privés qui elle en avait
fait la demande était regroupé tous les
tests de mon département les
pyrénées-orientales où il ya plus de
quatre cent mille habitants et nous
n'avions malheureusement qu'une
vingtaine à une trentaine de tests
possibles par jour
au centre hospitalier vous imaginez le
problème nous avions 1 kloster à
l'époque et la mise en place des tests
en privé est intervenue le 30 mars
voilà le décalage quant aux médicaments
nous avons eu une réunion je reprends
mes notes avec la fusée - tout ça c'est
tellement chesnais avec la direction
générale de la santé et pas celle là
voilà une réunion d'information le 13
mars avec dominique martens de la rsm
qui le 13 mars
d'après mes notes on a fait état des
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
médicaments et nous a dit effectivement
nous sommes très mobilisés on suit les
ruptures de stock enfin bon tout ça va
très bien et je note tout ça à ce jour
il n'y a pas de problème et pas de
conséquence sur la disponibilité des
médicaments en lien avec le co vie 19
dominique martin le 13 mars la suite a
bien prouvé le contraire
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement il a fallu suspendre
toutes les activités dans les
établissements de soins privés et je me
souviens parfaitement comment ça s'est
passé le week end du 15 mars où nous
avons su instruction d'arrêter toute
activité chirurgicale dans le week end
dans la clinique où j'exerce nous avons
vidé la moitié de l'établissement on a
bradé nos soins continus en service de
réanimation n'a fait un tableau de garde
et anesthésistes qui ont accepté
d'organiser une garde sur place on a
équipé une chambre pour qu'ils puissent
y dormir on a dégagé tout 46
quand je retire une personne après sur
le derrière ces siècles de hauteur et
j'arrêterai là dessus on a dégagé tout
un étage à la clinique 40 lits avec une
garde sur place des pneumologues nous
avions huit n'homologue on n'a pas vu un
seul patient tout a été sans
très à l'hôpital et les patients
hospitalisés au centre hospitalier été
suivi par les chirurgiens vasculaires et
par les ophtalmos je n'en dirai merci
beaucoup je vois que plus il ya de
manquer plus propos liminaires et le
fond mais je vois là où je vous laisse
continuer sur les propos liminaires on
essaie de cadrer sur deux trois minutes
parce qu'après il y aurait de très très
nombreuses questions sur lesquelles on
pourra revenir justement un très bien si
pour donner les préliminaires aller les
dates puisqu'il lui il était président à
cette époque je reprendrai la main prêts
pour vous donner le la prise en charge
globale par rapport au sein du carré et
par rapport aux professionnels de santé
merci beaucoup
donc on a appris aussi instruit pendant
les commissions les auditions j'ai
appris que qu'agnès busin avait senti
les choses le 10 janvier nous avons été
convoqués pour la première fois au
ministère le 18 février et parolier
véran 18 février il était prévue pour
les médecins libéraux que
le test les le kit de protection
devaient comporter charlotte masques
ffp2 et sur blues naturellement on n'a
rien vu arriver de tout ça le 27 février
les médecins de l'oise qui ce qui gère
les maisons médicales de garde menacent
de se mettre en grève parce que ils
n'ont toujours pas de masques ffp2 alors
que l'oise est déjà bien toucher et
j'interviens auprès du ministère et des
masques ffp2 arrive à 19h pour des
maisons de garde qui ouvre à 20 heures
et ils ont eu le plus grand mal à se
procurer les masques donc ça c'était le
27 février le le 26 février
on avertit ministère que il va y avoir
un massey un match à lyon alors qu'il ya
déjà eus le classeur de décontamine des
contamines et on nous dit qu'il n'y a
absolument aucun risque que ce match va
se tenir
donc lyon juventus se tient le 26
février
mieux alors que et le 1er mars il y à a
là encore lyon saint-etienne et un
brassage de la population de rhône alpes
auvergne et lui aps qu aura fort à la
démonstration que il ya eu une
recrudescence des cas en auvergne
rhône-alpes
quinze jours plus tard le ministère a
été prévenue et on nous a dit que les
experts direct est absolument aucun
risque
le 3 mars alors que nous manquons de
masques partout
marco pharma une entreprise de tourcoing
continue de vendre des masques à
l'étranger dans le même temps un
pharmacien un pharmacien de clamart qui
a réussi à se procurer quatre mille
masques très facilement des masques ffp2
apprend qu'il ne peut pas les vendre et
comme il a quand même acheté cher c'est
masquer la merveille de l'administration
française c'est que il a été obligé de
refourguer ses masques à son fournisseur
sans que nous on puisse en bénéficier
voilà la réalité voilà la réalité des
dates et donc on s'est retrouvés on
s'est retrouvé sans masque alors qu'on
pouvait en disposer de 4000 a dit ça
c'est pour les trains seront livrés au
dessus merci beaucoup de me donner la
parole juste pour les dates
ensuite nous avons fait en référer au
conseil d'état demandant la mise à
disposition pour les professionnels de
santé des masques
donc c'était le 25 mars ce référé a été
fait le 28 mars où on nous a pas donné
raison par contre comme par hasard le 28
mars ont commencé à voir des masques
donc on s'est dit qu'on avait quand même
peut réussir à faire quelque chose
c'était intéressant les choses
importantes à dire et à hull national
avoue on a fait des choses et aussi les
régions la région on a fait beaucoup de
choses et hellman hospital au centrisme
qui était vraiment déplorable où on nous
a demandé de demander aux patients
d'appeler le 15
donc il ya eu une surchauffe au niveau
du 15 et en même temps il ya eu une
impossibilité aux patients de venir
parce qu'on leur demandait de rester
chez eux donc il ya une perte de chance
quand même pour les gens qui étaient pas
coheed mêmes s'étaient quittés que vous
vite positif
puisqu'en fait on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait énormément de gens qui
étaient symptomatiques
on est un confrère qui a tiré la
sonnette d'alerme temps mulhouse docteur
rogge qui a montré qui a dit que dans
son cabinet il voyait environ 30 à 40
personnes qui étaient porteurs du coc
vide mais qui avait pas les symptômes
qui a été dit c'est à dire fièvre plus
ceux là tout est effectivement et on est
tombé sur ce fameux kloster qui a fait
qu'en fait ça a explosé de partout et il
travaillait sans masque
donc comme disait mon confrère non paul
ortiz
on l'a payé un lourd tribut puisqu'on
est à 51 décès dont 46 en libéral a
priori c'est les derniers chiffres qu'on
nous a fournie donc c'est quand même
très déplorable puisque effectivement on
a travaillé à manu on a travaillé sans
rien du tout donc ça c'est la première
chose à dire il est vrai que bon le
manque de masque bien évidemment le
manque de surdoses le manque de tests
ont fait qu'on est et qu'on finit au
niveau national de façon globale ce qui
n'était peut-être pas la meilleure des
choses à faire puisque maintenant on
fait les ont fait les détections il faut
détecter en masse et maintenant pourrait
le faire donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'important
on a confiné aux 6 à sainté un problème
assez grave
le confinement était fondée sur la peur
et cela la culpabilité et il aurait été
bien de le mettre en avant plutôt que
c'était un geste civique pour protéger à
la fois sa santé et celle des autres
puisque en fait les gens se sont mis à
avoir peur et on a maintenant les
conséquences de la peur d'une population
il ya à la fois la peur est à la fois la
solitude
donc non seulement la solitude des
personnes qui effectivement rester
rester en confinement chez eux mais on a
vu cette solitude aussi dans les maisons
de retraite et les ehpad où nous
intervenions aussi et où nous avions
aussi des fautes des uns possibilité
d'intervenir parce qu'en fait on
laissait faire entrer personne
donc il ya des enquêtes qui ont été
faites entre autres par le nps qui
montrait qu'il ya une rupture de soins
des le confinement
donc ça c'était quelque chose d'assez
grave puisque en fait toutes les
pathologies urgente toutes les
pathologies chroniques qui étaient
étiquetées soi disant qu vis de moi
puisqu'on sait pas puisque siviglia
local tesco a été fait et donc à une
perte de chance par rapport aux gens qui
ont été là donc tout ça on a décidé
chose qu'on pourra éventuellement vous
faire passer pour que ce soit annexé à
face là le problème les urgences avec
une prise d urgence qui était assez
difficile
donc on a réussi à organiser des couvées
de départ curkovic plus éco événement
afin d'y kobe de moi il ya le premier de
la reprise activités qui étaient assez
difficiles aussi puisqu'en fait on a
manqué quand même coup de mesures de
protection pour nous pour le personnel
il ya en fait il ya énormément de
personnes de professeurs de l'e-santé
qui n'était pas médecin comme les kinés
comme et comme les dentistes comme les
podologues qui nous ont fourni du
matériel
on a eu beaucoup de matériel qui ont été
fournis aussi par des par des personnes
qui étaient en contact avec nous donc ça
nous a permis de nous y allure ps
d'avoir de matériel qu'on a redistribué
on a fabriqué des blouses des surblouse
je vous en avais une que j'ai fabriqué
avec mme emma 100 mètres de fil pour
faire tout un tas de blues pour nos
infirmières qui est à domicile et
c'était grâce aux toiles d'hivernage que
que nos maraîchers parce qu'ils
enrichissent annuel de noir zonaux
fournit donc vraiment on a essayé de
faire le maximum avec quelque chose
comme cela
par ailleurs on a quand même une paire
d'activité qui est énorme puisque le
fait de tout envoyer sur le 15 est de
dire aux gens de rester chez eux
il ya une paire d'activités pour tous
les professionnels n'y a pas eu que
milieu d'établissement mais tous les
libéraux n'ont pour les médecins et ils
ont tourné entre 20 et 30% de leur
patelin elle si bien qu'ils aient aussi
une une perte de recettes qui était
assez conséquente et ça c'est quand même
incroyable quoi c'est à dire que c'est
une pandémie qui fait presque la
faillite des professionnels de santé
quand même quelque chose
et donc on a quand même pu bénéficier
c'étaient des choses qu on a été faire
après long que ma pour notre personnel
chômage partiel comme tout le monde de
télétravail des charges reportées avec
l'as cannes figure sauf la cnam qui nous
a permis de pouvoir faire de la télé
médecine et la première semaine ça a été
multiplié par 50
donc c'était vraiment très bien par
ailleurs la téléconsultation ne
remplaceront pas l'examen clinique
ils ne pourront pas faire ne pourra pas
remplacer dans les déserts médicaux les
médecins qui manquent donc nous avons
grâce à cela des possibilités de pouvoir
près de prise en charge et donc c'était
important
il ya des choses aussi par rapport aux
professionnels de santé compte y est
malade ou d'autres malheureusement sont
décédées dans quelques 14 et les
problèmes des indemnités journalières
qui ont été très tardivement admise et
puis on a le problème de la maladie
professionnelle actuellement qui est
encore en cours et donc ça c'est
important
donc on a pu intervenir grâce grâce à la
cnam qui a été très très très pertinente
et très rapide grâce à nous se révèle
pour pouvoir avoir des actes qui étaient
prises en charge à 100% en
téléconsultation télé télé au téléphone
puisque en fait on a beaucoup de
personnes âgées
beaucoup de zones blanches où on a pu
être au cours au contact les gens alors
ça va passer pas mais ça permettait
quand même d'asseoir bien no no no no
diagnostic et et tout ça ça a été aussi
bien prise en charge par rapport aux à
erez quand même on a noté c'était un
frein qui était plus ou moins prégnant
en fonction des régions puisque des
arriérés ce qui était très très
impliquée dans certaines régions et dans
d'autres c'était plutôt un frein entre
autres par rapport au centre qu'ovide et
donc les yeux ps et les fédérations des
heures ps puisque en fait c'est tout les
ures ps non seulement des médecins mais
d autres professions médicales ont ils
n'ont médical d'ailleurs ont permis une
évolution de l'organisation en local on
permet un accompagnement des
professionnels en ce que ce soit les
professionnels en structures
ambulatoires ou bien en cabine est une
organisation des filières une relation
très importante
hôpital ville très importante les
informations puisque on moque beaucoup
d'informations ça permet de le faire
d'avoir une coordination donc dans
l'approvisionnement est de pouvoir avoir
un rôle énorme au niveau des territoires
donc voilà donc sinon juste en
conclusion de deux secondes
en conclusion c'était d'écouter de faire
confiance aux professionnels de santé
leur laisser une certaine autonomie et
leur donner les moyens de ressources
suffisantes pérenniser les expériences
qui ont été concluantes
et puis aussi prévoir non seulement pour
pour enfin pour la suite et puis
peut-être c'est un second se rendent à
leurs frères nous y reviendrons dans les
bien sûr je pourrais la de prévoir la
suite
merci beaucoup bonjour on docteur
valérie du tyne donc je suis médecin
généraliste en exercice dans l'île
d'oléron
je suis ici parce que je suis
coordinatrice donc sur le secteur où
j'exerce du centre qu'ovide et vice
président de mg france
je laisserais ma consoeur le docteur via
notti parler plus des éléments généraux
déjà je pense que nous sommes
parfaitement d'accord avec les confrères
qui viennent de parlé précédemment
ensuite moi je ne suis plus venu pour
répondre aux questions sur
l'organisation de terrain comment ça
s'est mis en place un petit peu
lorsqu'on tanner m'ont d'abord il faut
le dire la part des professionnels de
santé qui se connaissaient sur le
terrain et de manière
dans la douleur un petit peu parce que
parce que sans trop dead sans moyens
avec un téléphone portable pour
s'appeler les uns les autres savoir
comment on allait s'organiser et
pourtant l'organisation s'est fait
spontanément sur tous les territoires de
manière relativement symétrique c'est ça
qui était très frappant c'est de voir
que à l'échelle des départements on se
retrouvait avec finalement les mêmes
problématiques dans chaque secteur est
finalement les réponses se trouvait
était à peu près les mêmes c'est à dire
que la première semaine on s'est dit on
va essayer d'organiser des filières dans
nos cabinets des horaires de pas mettre
les gens suspects en même temps que les
autres
et puis très vite on s'est rendu compte
que c'était compliqué que en fait faire
venir dans nos cabinets des gens
suspects au vide alors qu'on n'avait pas
de moyens de protection ni pour eux ni
pour nous ni pour la secrétaire des
moyens au niveau de l'hygiène du cabinet
qui était compliqué à obtenir
donc on a très très vite en une semaine
pris la décision d'organiser des centres
covit surtout sur tout le département
et on a vu ensuite en discuter entre
nous que ça s'était fait dans un certain
nombre de régions donc on a certainement
de de remonter de cet ordre voilà donc
je suis plus là pour répondre à ces
questions là dans kenya schiano tichy
médecin généraliste en exercice dans le
xviiie arrondissements dans un quartier
populaire de paris touchée de plein
fouet par l'épidémie un peu comme la
seine-saint-denis et tout le nord d'ace
de paris je suis là parce que je suis
vice président de mg france est aussi
présidente de la cés pts de paris 18e
donc ce qui est intéressant dans l'essai
pts et dans les centres coville dedans
dans tout ce qui a été mis en place
d'abord c'est que les médecins
généralistes ont été au rendez vous on a
été là du même avant le premier jour on
a commencé à se questionner bien avant
que les institutions se bouge et on a
été extrêmement inventif et on s'est
adapté aux différents territoires donc
par exemple ce qu'on a mis en place dans
le xviiie ne ressemble pas à ce qui a
été mis en place à l'île d'oléron les
réalités était différente donc on a des
populations différentes des moyens
différents d'aidé aux ressources
différentes et on a pu s'adapter au jour
le jour à ce qu'on connaissait de
l'épidémie aux besoins des populations
et à ce qu'on pouvait aux besoins des
professionnels aussi les médecins gêne
réalistes ont été au rendez-vous mais
pourtant j'ai jamais entendu une seule
fois monsieur salomon prononcer ce nom
une profession dont on ne prononce pas
le nom et à une profession qui n'existe
pas donc là je pense qu'il ya une
faillite je dirais presque de l'état
dans la mesure où la gradation des soins
c'est-à-dire soigner quelqu'un au bon
moment par la bonne personne au bon
endroit
ça n'a pas eu lieu on s'est pas appuyé
sur les soins primaires
or les soins primaires c'est là qu'on
prend le patient en charge au plus près
de lui qu'on répond le mieux à ses
besoins de santé
le parcours de soin partir de médecin
traitant qui le connaît qui connaissait
ces facteurs de risque sa précarité
sociale éventuellement et peu le guider
dans son parcours de soin ça n'a pas été
fait alors que c'est le lieu de la
prévention du dépistage des vaccins
donc effectivement on n'avait pas les
outils diagnostiques
on avait les moyens de profit de
protection des masques on en avait qui
nous reste il nous a été prochain pour
reprocher de ne pas en acheter mais on
en avait bien sûr on les a utilisés moi
je mets ffp2 je les ai même donné aux
infirmiers du territoire parce que
j'estimais qu'il était plus à risque que
moi mais il ya un moment où on pouvait
peut recommander j'ai presque été en
panne aussi de celui de tes
hydroalcoolique
donc franchement les médecins
généralistes mg france a fait des
enquêtes
trois enquêtes successives et la
première enquête montrait que les
généralistes avaient vu un million huit
cent cinquante mille patients et au bout
de la troisième enquête on en avait vu
deux millions ces deux millions personne
n'en a parlé ça n'intéresse personne
ça n'a pas la prétention d'être une
enquête scientifique
simplement ça mais un éclairage sur un
sujet qui n'a pas intéressé l'état
c'est-à-dire qui soigne ses patients en
ville
combien de patients ont été vus donc ça
ça pose quand même un problème cette
gradation des soins on a vu quand même
le dysfonctionnement du 15 1 avec un
seul décroché pour une question du genre
comment ça trappe le coc vide ou alors
je peux plus respirer qu'est ce que je
fais donc à une perte de chance pour les
gens qui avaient vraiment besoin de
soins urgents le 15 est indispensable on
en a besoin mais faut le recentrée sur
sa mission et se repose donc la question
du saas et de la régulation libérale
territoriales qui permet de ré
pondre au question de comment ça
s'attrape locaux vides est-ce que je
peux avoir un rendez vous parce que j'ai
mal au dos enfin aux questions qui ne
doivent pas passer par le casse donc ça
nous reproduisons pas les mêmes erreurs
si deuxième vague il ya six vaccins il
ya s'il vous plaît c'est pas à l'hôpital
c'est c'est vraiment sur les régulations
territoriales qu'il faudra les
organisations qui sont nés qui ont été
boostées moi je suis je tire un coup de
chapeau à tous les professionnels du
territoire si le monsieur le directeur
général de la santé ne l'a pas fait moi
je le fais parce que vraiment france
entière les collègues se sont bougés et
ont été au rendez vous et je suis à
votre disposition pour discuter de tout
ça écoutons mikko bonjour filet vermesch
je suis en activité à saint raphaël dans
le var et président du syndicat des
médecins libéraux
le témoignage que le sml versera
aujourd'hui est en réalité un retour
d'expérience tout d'abord nous
n'imaginions pas que la crise sanitaire
viderait les cabinets médicaux pendant
le confinement c'est quand même une
gageur l'activité a très fortement chuté
pour toutes les spécialités et certaines
d'entre elles celle notamment de
chirurgie ont été contraintes à l'arrêt
avec la mise en oeuvre du plan blanc
l'assurance maladie a chiffré à quatre
milliards d'euros le montant de soins
empêché pendant cette période
et si j'emploie le terme empêcher c'est
bien à dessein le gouvernement par sa
maladresse a conduit les passions à
croire qu'ils n'étaient pas autorisés à
se déplacer à se dépasser que pour des
soins urgents et ceux relatifs aux
qu'ovide et lorsque le message a été
rectifié sur votre insistance une forme
de psychose s'était développée sur le
risque de contamination dans les salles
d'attentes ce qui fait que les gens
avaient la psychose de se déplacer et ne
l'est même plus donc dans les cabinets
l'activité a donc été empêchée pour les
médecins et chirurgiens travaillent en
établissement de soins du fait du plan
blanc la demande du gouvernement de
vider les cliniques pour aider les
hôpitaux s'est fait sans distinction
entre les régions infectées et les
autres cela a mis à l'arrêt complet tous
les établissements avec des personnels
présents son travail parce que s'il
n'était pas là il n'avait pas le droit
au chômage partiel
l'activité aurait pu continuer sous
conditions limitant ainsi les sur
pathologique nous avons connu par la
suite
de même la reprise l'activité s'est vu
empêcher par les airs
est ce au motif qu'il fallait que les
établissements restent disponibles dans
un premier temps puis pour ne pas
consommer les produits servant à
l'anesthésié dans un deuxième temps ce
qui fait que début juillet nous avions
encore des problèmes pour hospitaliser
des patients qui avaient besoin d'être
sur lesquels on avait besoin
d'intervenir
l'activité a été empêchée aussi par
l'amour dans des médecins par les
pouvoirs publics
nous n'avons pas reçu à temps les
masques promis on nous a baladés sur les
stocks d'état qui en réalité n'existait
pas le discours politique évoluer en
fonction du stock de masques
je ne reviendrai pas sur la gestion des
masques est totalement ubuesque
pour exemple nous avons eu des
fourniture de masques alors en fonction
des régions c'était très différent mais
chez moi nous avons eu une fourniture de
masques très limité ffp2 en mars qui
avaient été fabriqués en 2002 est périmé
en 2007
alors qu'à l'époque la chaise disait que
deux ans de péremption ça pouvait passer
je tiens à souligner qu'à aucun moment
les médecins libéraux n'ont été avertis
du prétendu changement de doctrine
concernant la gestion des masques
à aucun moment ils n'ont reçu ni
directement ni indirectement la consigne
qui leur appartenaient désormais de
constituer leur propre stock sans quoi
il aurait fait le nécessaire pour
préserver leur propre santé celle de
leurs patients et bien sûr leurs
activités de soins au service de la
santé publique
je rappelle donc et ça a été déjà dit
que 46 médecins libéraux ont trouvé la
mort durant cette épidémie parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas équipés et il reste encore
difficile de chiffrer le nombre de ceux
qui ont été contaminés
lacarne fichiers face 6000 le nombre
d'arrêts de travail de médecins libéraux
en rapport avec cette pathologie
le sml s'inscrit aussi en faux contre le
procès d'intention fait par un homme
bachelot devant cette commission
les propos qu'elle a tenus sont tout
simplement déplacé à l'égard de notre
profession concernant la prise en charge
des patients les libéraux ont dû se
débrouiller par eux-mêmes les premiers
protocoles de prise en charge qui nous
ont été diffusées n'était ce pas adapté
à la pratique du cabinet on a dû des
rades et des protocoles de 24 30 pages
mais c'était c'est ubuesque à suivre
quand ce n'était pas assez simple les
médecins se sont organisés par eux-mêmes
pour créer des conditions de
consultation sécurisés dans leur cabinet
et avec l'instauration de centre
qu'ovide les collectivités locales y ont
prêté leur concours ainsi que les
entreprises
dans certains départements on peut
regretter à cet égard que les ars est
imposé un paiement forfaitaire dans
chacun des deux régions
intervenant devant les professionnels
intervenant dans ces centres et que
certaines d'entre elles n'ont toujours
pas payé
il y en a encore qui attendent leurs
émoluments des organisations ont
également été développés dans certains
départements en situation de pénurie
médicale dans la sarthe
par exemple les médecins ont trouvé les
moyens de prendre en charge les patients
s'entraîne sans médecin traitant sans le
concours des 7 pts des ars et déjà
acheter ils se sont appuyés tout
simplement sur des outils conventionnels
et le déblocage d'une consultation que
vides à 40 euros donc en négociations
avec le directeur de la caisse primaire
du département
ça a été un arrangement locale
le déverrouillage de la télémédecine a
été un levier incontestable mais plus
encore celui des consultations par
téléphone
il est indispensable de pérenniser les
consultations téléphoniques pour nos
patients les plus âgés qui ne savent pas
encore utilisé les moyens numériques et
ceux qui vivent dans ces zones blanches
ou mal couvertes par l'internet haut
débit
nous voulons également insisté sur la
gestion des appels le renvoie dans un
premier temps de tous les appels
relatifs foucault vide vers le centre 15
était une erreur
ces centres ont été rapidement débordés
générant des temps d'attenté de
traitement des appels inacceptables les
sens sans prise en charge de nombreux
patients dont covin en détresse sévère
vous avez eu récemment le rapport de la
fédération nationale des peuples des
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont victimes de
cette douloureuse expérience condamne
définitivement l'idée d'un numéro
d'appel unique dans les régions le 116
117 à fonctionner comme le grand test il
n'y a pas eu de difficulté il est
indispensable qu'à côté du 15 pour les
urgences vitales soit généralisé 1 116
117 pour les demandes de soins non
vitaux de la fille de la ville et que la
ville prend en charge le rôle de
régulation et stratégiques
il doit être confortée et développer
nous voulons ça souligné une dernière
anomalies les professionnels libéraux
des médecins les professionnels libéraux
bénéficie d'un dispositif de formation
continue obligatoire géré par l'état à
travers l' agence nationale du dpc nous
regrettons que l' agence nationale du
dpc et refuser de prendre en charge les
actions de formation relatives aux
qu'ovide au motif qu'elle n'était pas
dans les objectifs prioritaires du
gouvernement
donc la seule formation que les médecins
ont eu light et par le fonds d'actions
de formation le faf pm qui vit sur nos
cotisations mais les organismes d'état
vêtements failli dans cette mission elle
était pourtant nécessaire et urgente
ces actions les textes qui encadrent ce
dispositif de formation doivent évoluer
pour rendre celui-ci flexibles et moins
étatique
en conclusion les médecins libéraux
garde un sentiment très profond dans la
façon dont ils ont été traités et ma
consoeur précédemment le disait
ressentiment qui risque de s'alourdir au
vu de la différence de traitement entre
l'hôpital et la médecine ambulatoire que
nous entrons en voyant lors du ségur qui
doit se conclure demain je remercie
merci beaucoup je avons donné la parole
à monsieur le rapporteur gg trois points
à développer avec vous interrogation que
j'ai un premier point sur parliez tout à
l'heure de réponse sur les territoires
d'agilité de capacité à répondre d'abord
une première
et puis de recours à la ville un premier
point qui moi m'a interpellé c'est
finalement à ton manqué justement
d'agilité dans la réponse et nathan
peut-être pas trop calqué cette réponse
là sur un modèle connu qu'est la grippe
je m'explique c'est vrai qu au tout
départ on a eu des tests sur des
clusters avec recherche de passion zéro
etc
et puis très vite on arrive à la hausse
comme les autres épidémies
on arrête les tests ont conseillé à
quelqu'un qui est symptomatique est
symptomatique conteste pas donc est-ce
que ça c'est quelque chose à revoir pour
s'adapter à la pathologie surtout qu'en
plus on a appris par la suite que cette
pathologie pouvait être contaminante
avant même l'apparition des symptômes
donc avoir votre regard là-dessus
votre regard aussi évidemment sur vous
l'avez dit sur l'essai pts vous l'avez
dit aussi sur les moyens de
communication qui peut exister qui
peuvent exister entre entre
professionnels de santé parce que
souvent sont des boucles whatsapp qui
ont qui ont permis de communiquer sur
sur le terrain est toujours sur ce
point-là revenir sur la notion que vous
abordez sur la peur entre guillemets qui
avait été mise en place
est ce que est ce que est ce que
aujourd'hui on voit
on assiste à un certain relâchement dans
les mesures de sécurité y at il donc pas
parfois besoin de peur entre guillemets
deuxième point sur les masques il ya un
point qui qui avait été abordée avec je
voulais aborder avec vous c'est la
logistique de distribution des masques
puisqu'on a vu qu' il y avait pénurie de
masques mais aussi et vous l'avez
souligné dans vos propos liminaire une
désorganisation manifestement alors
certains dans certains articles on a pu
lire qu'il y avait une problématique
avec geodis qui avait été mandaté par
santé publique france sur des contrats
qu'ils avaient signés hockey est ce que
vous avez eu des informations dessus
quel est votre regard et puis enfin
troisième point un point un peu
comment dire taquin s'agissant de ce que
nous a dit roselyne bachelot
en audition je voudrais simplement
rappeler qu'elle s'est rattrapé je crois
pendant l'audition en disant que
c'étaient des mesures de précautions à
prendre avant hors période de crise
simplement je voulais vous vous
interrogez là dessus sur la question de
se dire sortons aussi de cette histoire
en progressant est-ce que vous pensez
que justement et c'est peut être un
sujet que vous avez abordé en disant que
vous n'aviez pas de notion de la
doctrine de 2013 l'état doit-il
accompagner les médecins via peut-être
une augmentation des critères de qualité
sanitaire avec eux pourquoi pas une
participation via les revenus
d'objectifs de santé publique ou quelque
chose dans ce style pour accompagner
donner des directives des organisations
d aide pour monter en qualité pour la
protection des patients et la protection
des des professionnels voilà les points
je voulais aborder avec vous au début et
je vous laisse répondre merci
ici si vous permettez sur vous sur vos
questions concernant la réponse
territoriale effectivement on s'est
débrouillé on s'est débrouillé c'est ce
qu'ils remontaient de tous les
témoignages du terrain on s'est
débrouillé parce qu'on s'est retrouvé
sans l'aide de l'état en particulier
dans ses services
déconcentré et heureusement que les
médecins libéraux ont pris la main aidé
il faut le dire par un les collectivités
locales
beaucoup de maires de président de
communauté de communes et cetera ont mis
des locaux à disposition pour monter les
centres coup vie qui sont montés par
tous ont amené des masses qui ont aidé à
la distribution de masques ffp2 qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d'entreprises du
voisinage ont accompagné les médecins
justement particules avec les masques
ils nous ont amené des masques qu'ils
avaient en particulier des ff pilote en
avait pas et heureusement qu'on a eu
cette agilité sur le terrain lyonnais on
a fonctionné comme je le dis souvent
mode dégradé qui soit ça marchait bien
en mode dégradé
parce qu'on n'a pas demandé les
autorisations on n'a pas respecter
absolument les règlements les lois etc
et si comme ça que ça devrait marcher
alors vous posiez la question est ce
qu'on n'a pas fait comme ça se fait
d'habitude mais oui malheureusement
d'habitude qu'est-ce qui se passe on
n'arrête pas de dire aux français
aller à l'hôpital pour tous et c'est ce
qu'on a dit vous appelez le 15 si vous
avez une suspicion de covin vous allez à
l'hôpital pour vous faire tester vous
allez à l'hôpital d'ailleurs au départ y
avait que quelques hôpitaux qu'ils
pouvaient faire les tests et puis après
on a un peu élargi
on a tous centrés sur une prise en
charge hospitalière et il faudrait que
nous organisions les choses exactement
al'inverse et au contraire au lieu de
dire comme le premier ministre je ne me
souviens plus quel jour
n'allez pas chez le médecin chez votre
médecin traitant
restez chez vous avec les conséquences
que ça eût il fallait au contraire
orienter la prise en charge des cas
suspects non graves bien sûr je ne parle
pas des urgences et les cas graves sur
une prise en charge en proximité sur
l'image pendant je vous interromps
là-dessus spa c'était une une notion que
j'avais aussi en tête on a eu quand même
l'impression que les gens alors
peut-être suite à des à des
interrogatoires et des affirmations de
quelques-uns mais on a eu quand même
l'impression qu'un certain nombre de
personnes ne souhaitait pas
allez à l'hôpital ou chez le médecin je
prends je suis désolé de te prendre mon
exemple personnel mais c'est survécu en
cabinet médical ou même à la régulation
15 où on a eu un certain nombre de
problématiques avec des gens et des
symptomatologie grave qui refusaient
l'autorisation mais monsieur le vice
président qui a fait passer le message
que les médecins libéraux étaient
organisées pour bien accueillir les
patients non l'a dit à nos passions
chaque fois qu'on avait des coups de
téléphone mais dans tous les cabinets
tout le monde s'est organisé on a
condamné un siège sur deux on a donné
des masques
alors moi quand j'ai entendu roselyne
bachelot j'étais hors de moi parce que
dans mon cabinet nous avions déjà acheté
par anticipation nous avions commandé
des des boîtes de 50 masques entre
parenthèses dans les à payer le tiers de
ce qu'elles valent aujourd'hui c'était
avant le c'était au tour juste y ont
commencé à parler de l'épidémie et tous
les médecins sont organisés certains
médecins demander aux gens de rester sur
le parking et les faisait rentrer un
parent etc
quand vous avez un premier ministre qui
dit n'allez pas dans les cabinets
médicaux parce que c'est dangereux
effectivement ils n'y vont pas je crois
que là il ya un vrai problème si je peux
compléter surtout surtout ne me laissais
ne laissez surtout pas l'état organiser
nos cabinets donnez nous les moyens
donnez nous les moyens de nous organiser
mais donnez nous les moyens nous
organiser mais ne dites pas à l'état de
faire les choses à notre place et parce
que là si vous voulez on vient
d'assister à une catastrophe je parlais
de recommandation ou dans le coma nation
donnez nous les moyens c'est laisser
nous laissez nous travailler vous savez
moi pour moi l'illustration de la
réactivité des médecins s'est laissé les
masques des quatre noms dans les
réanimations imaginé en temps de paix
que les réanimateurs et et demandé à
l'administration d'utiliser des masques
décathlon
on y serait encore comprenez et donc les
médecins ils se sont organisés
on a comme disait jean paul ortiz on a
mis un cas bien un siège sur deux on les
a condamnés on a mis du plexiglas dans
secrétariat
on a mis des bars etc on sait ont cédé
on s'est débrouillé avec les entreprises
qui nous ont donné qu'ils nous ont donné
des masques
on a est allé démarcher des entreprises
de peinture on était des faits marché
des entreprises de menuiserie d2 de
bricolage de lunettes etc
on s'est débrouillé avec nos moyens
d'accord et quand et pour revenir
simplement sur l'expérience de 2009
effectivement roselyne bachelot avait
des masques en 2009 mais son
administration
parce que j'ai assisté à la préparation
de dd fameux vaccinodromes on pensait en
haut lieu au ministère que les médecins
généralistes avait pas de frigo dans
leurs cabinets et que donc il ne
pourrait pas faire dix doses avec un
flacon de 10 et on a eu le droit au
fameux vaccinodromes 1 qui ont vacciné 6
millions de personnes alors que chaque
année les médecins généralistes
tranquillement sans faire de bruit en
vaccine 12 millions on est resté avec 94
millions de doses de vaccins sur les
bras et et la dire que roselyne bachelot
a été réhabilité et oser nous allumer
comme elle l'a fait devant votre
commission je peux vous dire que s est
mis pas mal de médecins à dos et et pour
nous nous on attend maintenant des
excuses parce que osé dire avec les cinq
mille plumes 5000 médecins contaminé 51
morts dont 46 médecins libéraux je peux
vous dire que ça ça va laisser des
traces
ça va laisser des traces donc les
médecins ce sont les médecins se sont
organisés et on a retrouvé la même
administration celle de 2009 qui a
méprisé la médecine libérale qui nous a
oubliés pour les masques qui a détourné
vers le centre 15
comme on l'a dit alors qu'on aurait très
bien pu le faire alors qu'on a eus qui a
détourné les patients des cabinets comme
l'a dit premier ministre en disant aux
gens aller faire renouveler vos mii de
vos ordonnances chez des pharmaciens
moi j'ai dû rappeler des patients dont
une dont je suis un très bien qui était
le cmx ou l'anticoagulant juste une
histoire des jeux vous allez pas resté
six mois sans voir venez voir vous serez
soyez tranquille vous allez voir on
dépénalise personnes effectivement on
travaillait entre 30 et 40 % de notre
activité et encore parce qu'on est dans
un groupe
alors que les autres musées de camarades
dijon 2 20% d'activité permettez moi de
vous dire
nous exprimer à titre personnel je crois
au nom de notre commission notre
reconnaissance notre respect vous avez à
bien des égards laisse éclater votre
colère et nous avons perçu votre
ressentiment sur ce qui s'est passé mais
pour ma part d'abord je veux rendre
hommage bien sûr aux médecins qui sont
décédés nous mesurons je crois que nos
concitoyens mesure le rôle qui a été le
vote que vous avez joué je veux vous
dire mon vous réitérer ma ma plus
profonde gratitude et ma reconnaissance
je voulais vous dire d'ailleurs dans cet
esprit mais vous l'avez abordé en
réponse aux questions du président j'ai
personnellement dit si même elle était
là j'étais entouré par deux futurs
ministres la semaine dernière madame
bachelot n'allant bourguignon que je
trouvais le propos de madame bachelot à
la fois injuste et et non pertinents
mais au-delà de cette appréciation est
vous l'avez évoqué et nous en prenons
naturellement un beau bonne note et ça
ne m'étonne pas je voulais vous
interroger sur la façon de ce que vous
avez dit je considère tout à l'heure que
vous n'aviez jamais eu d'informations
sur la nécessité de constituer ce stock
ni des ars ni de l'ordre voilà parce que
on a eu un débat d'ailleurs hier ici
même
et un point extrêmement important pour
éclairer notre commission de la part des
fédérations hospitalières privée qu'elle
soit du créatif et non lucratif disant
que la doctrine qu'on évoque celle du
secrétariat général de la défense
nationale qui dit il faut que les
entreprises les professions médicales et
chef dans les employeurs médecins aussi
être un employeur se dote des stocks de
protection est en tout cas je voulais
vous demander si voilà vous nous
confirmez bien que d'aucune instance ou
de tutelle ou syndical où on l'a appris
on appris lors de votre de leur
condition que ce courrier
que vous évoquez peut-être parce que
nous ce qui nous importe c'est un sujet
qui montent de plus de plus en plus dans
l'actualité la possibilité de 7,2
seconde vague est quasi annoncée
aujourd'hui l'inquiétude au plan
international c'est pour vous d'ici
septembre vont dans les jours qui
viennent rogner quelle organisation il
faut mettre en place pour qu'on ne
réitère pas les ce que vous avez vécu
subi ce que vous venez de rappeler avec
des mots très très fort et est très est
très important notamment dans la
répartition des des équipements de
protection individuelle dans les masques
dans les blues et puis je voudrais vous
vous interrogez aussi parce que parmi
vous fâchez pas ici mais les médecins
libéraux en exercent souvent aussi un
rôle de médecin coordonnateur dans les
ehpad et je voudrais avoir votre
ressenti de la façon dont a été géré la
situation dans les ehpad notamment sur
la liberté de prescription et ça rejoint
les ehpad mais ça ça dépasse le cadre
des ehpad sur la question de l'atteinte
à la liberté de prescription médicale et
puis notamment sur ce qui s'est passé
aussi dans dans la prise en charge des
résidents des ehpad qui pour le coup
pour beaucoup n'ont pas été hospitalisés
auquel il ya eu en fonction du décret du
28 mars la mise en place d'un traitement
sédatif
voilà un traitement palliatif s comment
vous l'avez comment vous l'avez vécu la
foi et surtout si vous avez été
confrontés à cette difficulté de prise
en charge d'hospitalisation de patients
dans les ehpad g vos confrères un
médecin niçois qui me disait moi j'ai
appelé j'appelais la régulation on m'a
dit bon de toute façon dont patients qui
meurent chez nous qui meurent chez toi
c'est pareil donc il va rester chez toi
bon est ce que ça vous avez ce vécu est
ce que ça s'est reproduit est-ce que
vous avez eue été témoin de consignes
particulières d'une doctrine
particulière sur les épate je vous
remercie
oui sur le sur la pratique de la
deuxième vague et sur l'organisation
je crois qu'il faut tirer les
enseignements de ce qui s'est passé est
effectivement donné clairement des
instructions aux français quand le
confinement a été décidé moi j'ai été
très étonné de voir que globalement
alors bien sûr qu'il ya des exceptions
les gens qui l'ont pas respectivement
fin de globalement les français ont été
tes d'une responsabilité extraordinaire
ils ont suivi le confinement
je me rendais à mon cabinet et à ma
clinique tous les jours j'ai jamais été
contrôlé et je constatais que
effectivement les français le respecter
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui quand on
voit les risques d'une deuxième vague
regardons ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays étrangers comment ils ont
fait iso tester donc il faut continuer
effectivement à tester très largement
ils ont confiné dans les clusters et
depuis hier
regardez ce qui se passait dans certains
pays étrangers en catalogne il décide le
port obligatoire du masque dans tous les
endroits confinés
pourquoi en france on ne fait pas on
attend quoi
on attend quoi on attend qu'il y ait des
kloster partout il faut quand même être
clair vis-à-vis des français je crois
que ça a manqué ce type d'instructions
on n'a pas eu ce type d'instructions
alors on a on a aujourd'hui un
déconfinement tout le monde oublie
gestes barrière dont je crois
qu'aujourd'hui faut être clair on est
encore dans une situation qui est entre
guillemets sous contrôle avec le cluster
mais il faut effectivement donné des
instructions claires aux français en
particulier sur le port de masques et le
renouvellement des mesures barrières
tombent actuellement des endroits
confinés sur l'organisation
là aussi tirons les enseignements de ce
qui s'est passé pendant la crise du coc
vie 19
qu'est ce qui a bien marché quand les
professionnels de terrain en particulier
médecins libéraux se sont organisés ont
pris la main et c'est bien comme ça
qu'il faut organiser les choses il faut
donner les moyens et faire confiance aux
professionnels de terrain de s'organiser
on a des centres covit qui ont été
montées qui aujourd'hui sont dans
beaucoup d'endroits entre guillemets en
sommeil nique sur les endroits où on
peut faire les tests diagnostiques de rt
pcr
donc il faut se préparer ne pas
complètement les désarmer donner les
moyens en priorité à ses centres
qu'ovide pour éviter que tout le monde
aille à l'hôpital pour pour tout et pour
rien parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
évitera cet engorgement terrifiant qui a
eu dans les hôpitaux
donc au niveau organisationnel comme en
le disais tout à l'heure il faut se
reposer sur la proximité sur les
médecins de proximité et les accompagner
dans les structures et des organisations
qui mettent en place se pose le problème
très clairement drs et des délégations
territoriales des ars je pense que là à
un moment donné il va falloir que
courageusement ans
vois pourquoi certaines ars et beaucoup
délégations territoriales ont été des
obstacles et des freins à ce qu'on
voulait et ce qu'ont essayé de mettre en
place sur le terrain pour répondre à vos
questions
donc par rapport à effectivement faut
tirer les conséquences de ce qui a été
fait pour éviter de refaire les mêmes
erreurs et surtout profité des choses
qui ont été très actives et très positif
pour pouvoir les mettre en avant
donc effectivement arrêtons arrêtons le
système administratif
c'est pas des gens qui connaissent rien
de la médecine qui vous apprendre la
médecine c'est pas des gens qui
connaissent rien les médecines qui nous
empêchait de prescrire l'interdiction de
prescription des médicaments mais
écoutez c'était une honte on est quand
même capable de savoir ce qu'on prescrit
ou alors qu'on nous retire notre cap
notre diplôme de docteur en ce moment en
france comment le jockey docteur bon
mais là effectivement stop stop par
rapport à par rapport à la seconde vague
il faudrait aussi tirer les conséquences
par rapport à toute allure ma consoeur
en parler mais tout ce qui se fait sur
le terrain c'est à dire qu'actuellement
ça rejoint un petit peu le système de la
recherche la recherche en milieu libéral
est extraordinaire on a fait des
échanges sur nos forums
on savait on savait que dans les ehpad
par exemple on n'avait pas du tout les
mêmes symptômes de co vite que dans que
quand on voyait en réanimation
on voyait les premières personnes c'est
les deux personnes âgées qui tombe et on
voyait les mamies c'était ma michele
d'hémorragie vaginale et sa petit à
petit on a tiré
on a tiré les sonnettes d'alarmé on a
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé par rapport à
la gueuse il agnosie donc c'était vers
la perte du goût et la perte de la perte
de l'odorat et ça c'était vraiment un
signe que ce qu'on appelle nous presque
pas tognum unique c'est-à-dire qu'ils
signent presque la maladie voyons
énormément progressé parce que par
rapport à la grippe
c'est vrai qu'on a on l'a entendu
puisque c'est arriver de partout comme
quand on était ça va être une grippette
quoi comme partout il est vrai qu'on n'a
pas non plus
su ce qui se passait vraiment en chine
non plus donc on est reparti avec avec
cela et puis petit à petit on a tiré des
conséquences
alors il est vrai que les gens qui
voyaient des personnes à l'hopital on me
respecte et on lui réanimation c'était
pas du tout les mêmes qu'on pouvait voir
en libéral je redis mois qu'il ya des
médecins libéraux comptent ils auraient
la sonnette d'alarmé
ils n'ont pas été écoutés on a attendu
dix à quinze jours avant de pouvoir
tirer les conséquences de ce qu'il
disait et il avait raison
faut savoir écouter nous on est à
l'écouté de nos passés on voit comment
ils évoluent au l'on pouvait être qu'ils
sont et c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
impérativement tirer donc te donner la
possibilité de faire de la recherche en
médecine générale
la deuxième chose effectivement c'était
de pouvoir faire cette formation ce
qu'on a fait nous entre nous c'est à
dire que dès qu'on avait un symptôme on
pouvait on se le dise r on avait des
réseaux qui permettait de savoir
exactement ce qu'ils pouvaient avertir
que c'était locaux vides et ça a été
très très très porteur donc là il ya
aussi des choses à tirer parce que ça a
été le système descoings qu'ils aient
boîte ça peut nous des petits des gros
google et des choses comme cela
par rapport à tout ce qui était présent
cher nous refaites fait fait un double
système d'appel d'urgence le 15 c'est
pour les urgences vitales comme par
hasard et puis l'infarctus avait plus
d'avc et bien aidé a fixé il ya bien les
infarctus et pour les quelques quelques
retours de personnes qui on n'ouvrait
plus la porte et ont trouvé quelqu'un de
décidé derrière la porte quand les
pompiers ouvrait la porte donc tête il
mort du co vite puisque beaucoup de
cowitz étaient dus à des problèmes
vasculaires et des problèmes de
thrombose mais est-ce que c'était pas
mal infarctus ou un avc coke était resté
là chez lui parce qu'il n'avait pas pu
appeler le 15
donc prévoir un double système 15 appels
d'urgence et le 116 117 ou pour la
régulation libérale quelque chose de
très important très très important c'est
aussi un respect par rapport à nos
patients c'est un respect de la le des
médecins libéraux qui travaille toujours
comme ça quelque part puisque l'appel dé
rsa c'est bien aussi un appel aux sivs
entre nous pour pouvoir avoir une
régulation donc saisi pour lever le
problème de la seconde vague
la seconde vague wii donc on n'aura pas
non plus le problème des tests puisque
maintenant il ya presque trop alors à
moi le problème les masques parce qu'on
en voit partout même sur les trottoirs
et vous parliez les ehpad puisqu'on n'a
pas parlé des fans nous c'est vrai dans
notre coin alors les de la chanson
n'avait pas trop de problème et on n'a
pas eu deux decaux vite dans l'aude en
aux ehpad
enfin c'est quand même quelque chose de
très important mais on l'a su le
personnel était aussi très démuni
puisqu'en fait il n'était pas
approvisionnée en masque il était pas on
n'a pas fait de détection
on n'a pas fait de bessières je suis le
personnel les ehpad ce qui est quand
même pas normal donc c'est des choses à
faire régulièrement
donc ça c'est lé deuxième chose et puis
là une chose importante
stop quoi on a déshumanisé le soin avec
le co vide
les gens sont morts comme des malheureux
chez eux on a laissé nos personnes âgées
tout seul mais qui sont morts de
solitude enfin quand même mais on est
dans une société une société reconnue
belle parce qu'elle respecte ses anciens
parce qu'elle respecte ces jeunes parce
que aussi le problème avec les écoles
c'est pas tout à fait notre domaine mais
il ya eu ce problème là aussi on voyait
les poufs gas mc aux plus touchés qui
n'ose pu être en contact et qui sont eux
aussi déprimé donc vous voyez il ya
plein de choses par rapport à ça où il
faut reprendre les choses et ré
humaniser le soin et voilà merci papa
c'est aux questions de deux groupes
monsieur d'or pour les républicains
merci merci monsieur le président je
crois que vous confirmez tous à
l'unanimité la capacité de protéger la
médecine de ville et en particulier en
commençant par la désinformation sur les
stocks médicaux on a eu l'exemple
démasqué en sont l'illustration parfaite
puisqu'un jour gouvernement disait les
masques ne sont pas utiles et puis
quelques jours plus tard les masques
sont utiles si on avait effectivement
adopté les les
ce que c'est ce qui se passait à hong
kong en asie vietnam en allemagne etc
ce problème serait pas là vous avez payé
un lourd tribut vous l'avez rappelé tous
en malheureusement décès de
professionnels et puis en nombre de
personnes qui ont été touchées
d'ailleurs je crois qu'ici elle à table
quelqu'un je connais a été
particulièrement touché un certain
moment par le cos vite 19 oui tu t'en es
bien remis et simplement les
points essentiels en dehors des masques
problème des ars serait intéressant de
savoir vraiment quels ont été les
mauvais lien entre les ars et les
professionnels libéraux de terrain parce
que ça je les ai entendus y compris chez
moi la fermeture des cabinets au 15 mars
a permis le développement de la
téléconsultation d'ailleurs laquelle je
suis particulièrement attaché
qu'est ce qu'elle va devenir est-ce que
la téléconsultation doit rentrer
maintenant dans l'est les pratiques
générales dans les territoires où est-ce
que ça va revenir en arrière et ce que
la téléconsultation et maintenant
réellement partie enfin je voudrais vous
dire puisqu'on parlait de l'avenir ce
numéro de téléphone libérale voulues par
beaucoup d'organisations syndicales le
licol tous le 116 117
est-ce qu'il doit pas enfin être mis sur
le terrain à côté du 15 après si vous
avez d'autres questions
on se doit répondre eh ben on est à côté
de ce 116 117 puisque pas vous parliez
des de la permanence des soins libéral
est ce que cette permanence des soins
ambulatoires doit pas être renforcée ou
trouver un système qui améliorent la
permanence des soins deux puisque on
maintient et moi je fais partie de ceux
qui maintenait le volontariat mais est
ce que il faut pas amélioré la
permanence des soins sur dans tous les
territoires songerait que je suis assez
surprise des soupes pièces d'or souvent
amusé gagner attention pourtant toi tu
en fais partie les soutiens financiers
des cabinets libéraux
je veux que le parent paris plat et par
la carmi puisque je crois savoir que
vous avez eu des soutiens de la part de
l'état mais également de votre
organisation de retrait de la caisse des
retraites
important de montrer une caisse des
retraites important merci monsieur val
ou un fond sonore vous avez non je vais
quand même continuer de présider si ça
ne vous dérange pas voilà monsieur
vallot s'il vous plaît merci bonjour le
plus président en présence se rebiffe
bon d'abord merci merci beaucoup pour
pourpre aux interventions et pour vos
témoignages je veux dire que sa queue on
a eu quelques auditions qui ont pu
parfois laissé le sentiment qu'au fond
tout s'était bien passé que derrière la
formule l'hôpital a tenu bon et on a dû
creuser un certain nombre d'auditions
pour savoir finalement ce qui avait été
compliquée à gérer pour préparer pour
préparer la suite vous ayez beaucoup de
choses la première chose qui me paraît
important de fiction c'est la question
des ehpad et espèce de choc
anthropologique quand même que ça révèle
dans notre rapport dans notre rapport au
vieillissement et je crois je le dis aux
rapporteurs qui aura vraiment sur ce
plan de ce qui s'est passé dans les
ehpad des points à creuser peut-être
voir s'il ya des comptes rendus de chsct
a regardé peut-être avoir des rapports
de retranscription des échanges qui a pu
avoir entre les centres 15 et les ehpad
et il ya quelque chose qui s'est noué
vers moi c'est sur deux points que je
voudrais avoir un peu plus de précision
de votre part parce que vous étés très
complet sur beaucoup de choses
c'est sur votre le rapport entre
cliniques privées et hôpital public on
doit dire que dans la dans la crise on
s'est un peu interrogé sur les
transferts d'un certain nombre de
patients d'un bout à l'autre de la
france alors que on nous disait qu'il y
avait des capacités d'hospitalisation
dans les cliniques privées ont joué à
savoir ce qu'il en a puisque là aussi
nous avons des sons de cloches qui
pressent un peu un peu contradictoire la
deuxième chose c'est que
à mesure qu'on nous avons ces auditions
le sentiment qu'il notre aussi peut-être
que ce démenti par un collègue c'est que
on a eu une loi sur l'urgence des
urgences sanitaires qu'il était en fait
un état d'urgence pandémique et que sur
le plan des autres questions sanitaires
on est passé un peu à côté vous avez
évoqué les pertes de chance ne nous
reçoit le problème de continuité dans un
certain nombre de gens devraient savoir
si on est capable ou pas de faire un
bilan sanitaire de cette pandémie je
vais lire indépendamment de ce qui
concerne le kovy directement s'est dit
il ya eu des infarctus et c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs même à l'hôpital public
certains certains médecins mg b bien sûr
qu'ils vont continuer à faire des
infarctus mais les fonds chez eux parce
qu'ils n'osent pas venir donc est ce
qu'on est capable d'apprécier le bilan
sanitaire
orco bin voila pour préparer la suite et
pour que si nous devons avoir une
seconde phase on n'oublie pas qu'il ya
d'autres pathologies
merci beaucoup quand on est actuellement
au c ur de la santé et qu'on est
complètement ignoré du ségur de la santé
et qu'on ignore la médecine libérale
comme l'administration nous a ignorés et
méprisés
parce que on a été méprisée quand il
s'est agi des primes
souvenez vous que les internes en
médecine générale qui effectuent leur
stage en médecine générale était
initialement privés de primes et que les
anesthésistes général réanimateurs
libéraux qui ont permis au système de
tenir était initialement privé prime il
a fallu qu'on se bat pour que ces gens
qui ont permis au système de tenir soit
également bénéficie également des primes
donc voilà le le mépris donc le 116 117
oui mais là il va falloir insister parce
que je peux vous dire que le
gouvernement n'ait pas disposé à ça
n'est pas prêt de faire 1 116 117
libéral et pourtant c'est la première
étape d'une réorganisation du système de
soins et d'une prise en charge des soins
non programmés et d'une régulation des
urgences quand on voit qu'on la mène 7
milliards actuellement là et que les
hôpitaux mégote moi je peux vous dire
que si vous mettiez 5 milliards sur la
médecine de ville maintenant on vous
réorganise le système de santé 1 et a
commencé peut-être par le financement
aussi des syndicats médicaux parce que
je peux vous dire que là nous on a tous
barrés nos journées on nous prévient la
veille pour le lendemain comme si nous
on avait pas de consultation on n'est
pas des professionnels du syndicalisme
on a tous une activité libérale et là la
façon dont on nous a traités pendant ce
séjour de la santé avec des réunions qui
était modifiée la veille
mais annulée et c est là nous annoncer à
9h51
une réunion demain à 11 heures au
ministère c'est un pur scandale un donc
sur le codé des agences quand j'ai
entendu agnès buzyn dire que peut-être
il faudrait créer une nouvelle agence
pour la gestion des crises excusez-moi
des agences quand vous pensez j'ai aussi
instruit penser de cette enquête 1 on a
appris que le directeur de santé
publique france écrit en 2017 au
directeur général de la santé concernant
la gestion des dd des stocks etc et qu'
il a une réponse il s'en préoccupent en
octobre 2018 et qu'on s'en préoccupe ans
en octobre 2018
marc comment agnès buzyn l'apprend la
prendrai pas ce qui se voit tous les
trucs en janvier en janvier 2020 donc il
faut quinze mois pour aller d'un étage à
l'autre dans ce ministère et crée une
nouvelle agence est quoi faire quoi
faire je vous rappelle que la rs ile de
france qui a pourtant été
particulièrement active et qui a créé un
modèle du genre distri masque comme ce
qui a été mis en place dans le grand est
avec les u rps médecins et sûrs ps
pharmaciens pour la distribution des
masques
il ya une distribution à peu près
identique mais qui s'est mise en place
seulement le 20 mars en ile de france
elle a été réactif mais mais la rs qui
envoient des directives concernant les
pistes les clusters le 11 avril
quand moi j'ai un cluster en face chez
moi et bien la rs n'applique pas les
directives qu'elle envoie normalement on
aurait dû extraire les sept personnes
qui étaient dans le foyer de jeunes
travailleurs et les mettre dans un hôtel
qu vide or ça n'a pas été le cas et là
j'ai découvert aussi la guerre des
polices
là entre la préfecture et les ars car le
maire m'a prévenu que le préfet n'avait
pas été prévenu de ce cluster à clamart
donc si vous voulez on découvre il ya
une administration hypertrophique et est
qui et qui justement sont plus ce fait
la guerre
donc tout ça c'est absolument tout ça
c'est absolument insupportable je
voudrais tu devrais répondre
est-ce qu'on a eu des courses sérieux et
sur le risque la gestion du risque
absolument pas n'a jamais eu un seul
cours dans nos études médicales sur la
gestion du risque absolument aucun après
est ce qu'il ya des risques par chez
vous c'est vrai j'habite en ralliant
c'est le val de loire on arrive
inondations alors ça il ya des plans qui
sont tirés sur la comète et des pages
comme sa personne les ouvre et en fait
on dit on a fait quelque chose et on n'a
rien on a on allie oui on a en a on
allie nucléaire parce que nous l'a quand
même à ça pas de centrales nucléaires on
est au courant de rien vionne n'est même
pas distribué
enfin ça devient invraisemblable quoi
invraisemblable oui bah y'a des durs
qu'ils me disent que ça patine
oui bah c'est pas distribuer partout
puisqu'en fait il ya des gens qui ne
l'ont pas donc est-ce qu'ils sont pas et
cherche et j'en sais rien en tout cas
toujours est il que ça y est j'ai une
époque c'est pas les gens qui n'ont pas
voulu le distribue aussi des gens qui
sont pas allés chercher en faut quand
même pas enfin bon oui il nous avait
tout à fait mais quand on distribue et
ça veut dire que les gens ne l'ont pas
automatiquement avec eux c'est donc ça
c'est clair il faut une information
aussi du public parce qu'ils se rendent
même pas compte à quoi ça peut servir
donc ça c'est les choses par rapport à
la liberté de prescription alors là
madame oui on rue dans les brancards
c'est une atteinte à notre liberté de
prescription c'est une atteinte à notre
profession c'est une atteinte à notre
dignité
c'est quelque chose d'insupportable ça
c'est certain
par rapport à tout ce qui été dit par
rapport à la coordination dans les
cabinets médicaux et puis savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé ça
continue on est en train de faire des
autos c'est ce que maintenant les
autotests pour que les gens parce que
les gens la chasse a montré que les
autres tests n'étaient pas très fiable
comme tout les tests d'ailleurs y'a
aucun test qui est fiable à 100% mais
que les gens pourront le faire mais en
même temps ils veulent pas que les gens
le fasse parce qu'ils seront pas
capables d'interpréter donc ça pourrait
être des tests qui seraient prescrits
par les médecins
remboursez hop on en sait rien fait par
d'autres professionnels de santé mais en
fait problème de santé publique c'est
exactement le même la lisibilité on le
saura où qui a fait qui a fait le coup
vie qui ne l'a pas fait on n'en saura
rien donc il est quand même quelques
lecteurs aussi au niveau du gouvernement
et au niveau de l'état de faire un
système de santé publique
c'est hyper important parce que c'est
vrai que nous on voit les personnes en
tant qu'individu on les problèmes du
contact a effectivement fallait
dire les problèmes des cas contacts qui
nous ont posé aussi un problème sur le
plan déontologique puisqu'il fallait
même s'il peut installer t'es pas
d'accord il fallait le dire de signaler
ce qui paraît logique dans le sens de la
santé publique et individuelle
c'est ça l'était moins mais néanmoins
ses problèmes de dos autotests il va
falloir aussi s'y pencher parce que
c'est la suite pour demain c'est à dire
que si on dit oui enfin le test seraient
post est positif est qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'après cette personne en fait tu
développes aco vide et on décède par
exemple quelle sera la responsabilité de
la personne qui leur a fait ou est ce
que ça va être tracé puisqu'on parle de
traçabilité actuellement donc tout ça il
ya énormément de choses à revoir
ça sera peut-être pas fait avant la
deuxième vague mais des choses à revoir
pour le futur c'est à dire faut
construire de nous de nos erreurs mais
il faut pas recommencer les mêmes et
c'est vrai qu'il y avait nos confrères
qui disait qu'on fait les médecins
manquent et de masquer que l'état masque
et les manques donc c'était une phrase
que j'avais trouvé assez assez bien mais
ça dit quand même quelque chose par
rapport à tout ce qu'on a pu nous dire
pour nous faire si on va passer la
parole intimidation pour continuer dans
la même lignée c'est vrai que la santé
publique c'est vraiment une des missions
de la médecine générale et des soins
primaires et ça faut que ce soit
vraiment marqué et jusqu'à présent ça
n'était probablement pas vous avez parlé
de poser la question sur les recueils de
données en médecine générale et en soins
primaires c'est fondamental j'avais
commencé mon propos par sa façon le fait
que ça n'intéressait personne
il y avait un réseau sentinelles pour la
grippe à l'époque l'a été
disparu enlevée et ce réseau sentinelles
s'appuyer sur le réseau des médecins
généralistes nous sommes quarante cinq
mille vrai généralistes en france je dis
vrai parce qu'après il ya des exercices
où ils sont comptabilisés mais ils font
autre chose que de la médecine générale
mais y avait quarante cinq mille
professionnels sur sur tout le
territoire car soir l'ensemble de la
population
c'est quand même un réseau sur lequel on
peut s'appuyer me semble utile donc je
pense que ça serait bien de le faire
revivre sur la téléconsultation la
téléconsultation a été un outil très
important et très intéressant mais il
faut faire attention aussi à ses limites
la limite c'est le respect du parcours
de soin c'est à dire que ça montre
effectivement qu'une télé consultation
hors sol par quelqu'un capable mais le
malade physiquement qui le connais ni
d'eve ni d'adam qui l'appelle à 600 km
en général se traduit par après une
visite aux urgences où aller voir votre
médecin parce que effectivement ça c'est
en gros à rien ou quoi et aussi aux
limites de la téléconsultation par
rapport à la clinique quand c'est dans
le cadre du parcours de soins comme cela
l'a été la lame à grande majorité des
téléconsultations quand il dit que
c'était une aux patients qui nous
appelaient ou au téléphone ou dans une
vraie téléconsultation suivant les
territoires moi mes patients dans le
xviiie ils savent même pas télécharger
une application donc ça a été téléphone
heureusement qu'il y avait le téléphone
ça permettait de suivre l'évolution
d'une pathologie chez un patient qu'on
avait vu moi il est certes un patient si
je leur demande vous avez de la fièvre
et comprennent même pas ma question
donc c'est pas au téléphone ou en télé
consultation que j'aurai la réponse
j'aurai besoin de le voir physiquement
donc celui là il me faut des protections
pour le voir correctement
donc c'est un mélange des deux c'est
indispensable mais à la fois il ya des
limites
le respect du parcours de soin et aussi
bien sûr on a besoin de cliniques le les
restrictions de prescription c'est
absolument scandaleux et c'est une des
revendications de notre syndicat mais
aussi des autres depuis longtemps là
c'est très médiatique donc on en parle
beaucoup et il ya beaucoup de
restrictions présets de prescription qui
passe par votre assemblée me semble-t-il
dans des décrets qui nous interdisent de
prescrire de nombreuses molécules
alors il ya des nouveaux médicaments ou
le prix est telle que je comprends qu'on
veut y mettre un filtre pour que tout le
monde ne prescrivent pas des médicaments
à 10000 euros le comprimé mais expliquez
moi pourquoi la ventoline en aérosol est
interdite aux médecins généralistes
j'aimerais bien qu'une seule personne
n'explique ça c'est inimaginable
donc c'est pas d'aujourd'hui c'est
scandaleux mais c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
et parfois c'est voter dans cette
assemblée
la gestion de crise
je passerai peut-être la parole tout à
l'heure à ma collègue qui a un passé sur
sur le sujet mais il faut s'appuyer sur
des organisations territoriales vous
disiez que le tu disais que le nombre de
ces pts étaient limités c'est vrai mais
comme dans toutes les crises
ça fait naître des choses ça oblige à
innover ça oblige à se bouger et donc
les organisations territoriales qui
était naissante ont vraiment eu un coup
de boost je vais vous donner l'exemple
de paris puisque je suis parisienne
décès pts consigne est lassé il y en a
trois au jour d'aujourd'hui le 13e le
14e le 18e il y en avait qui était en
gestation le dixième le 15e le 20e et il
ya des territoires où il ya vu poids
tellement grand chose et qui ont fait
descendre au lido les dynamiques
territoriales sont nés c'est le
cinquième le douzième le 17ème le 19e
vous voyez qu'on commence à couvrir pas
loin du tout paris est donc là s'il ya
une gestion de crise qui nous associe à
nouveau un niveau de l'étagé dirai où on
est dedans pour donner notre avis est
pas faire des choses uniquement
administratifs qui seront inapplicables
et qu'on peut ensuite décliné sa et
s'appuyer sur des organisations
territoriales qui sont pas parfaites il
ya des trous dans la raquette mais on
voit bien que séné est là pour la suite
faut absolument booster ça parce que ça
sera un outil indispensable ainsi
beaucoup monsieur gautier
merci monsieur le président je pourrais
revenir sur plusieurs questions mais
notamment sur la question des ehpad qui
est un des gros échec de cette crise me
semble-t-il vous avez tous souligné les
difficultés de tester de soigner
d'hospitaliser les résidents il ya là un
problème médical et un problème éthique
tout simplement mon problème d'humanité
ça a été rappelé alors on a signalé les
questions d'interdiction de prescription
la médecine libérale repose sur
plusieurs piliers liberté d'installation
liberté de choix du médecin par le
patient et liberté de prescription et là
il ya quand même question et en plus de
ces interdictions
il ya un deuxième aspect c'est qu'il ya
aussi des recommandations des
préconisations des incitations à
prescrire et je voudrais avoir votre
avis votre point de vue sur le décret
signé par lille et veyran le 28 mars sur
l' usage du rivotril notamment pour les
résidents en ehpad
merci beaucoup écouté je vous laisse
répondre oui merci
il ya beaucoup de questions en même
temps donc je répondrai à deux ou trois
comme ça chacun peut s'exprimer
pas forcément sur tout mais sur quelques
points vous parliez des masques on
attaquer il faut quand même le dire en
attaque et ste crise avec les stocks
qu'on avait reçu il ya dix ans moi je
fais déjà fait des masques et des
lunettes de protection de l'époque ils
étaient périmés mais au moins on avait
ça dans nos cabinets on avait des
petites boîtes où il y avait je dirais
25 ou 30 masques trente masques avec les
lunettes de protection on a on a attaqué
comme çà et dont dans mon cabinet on
avait acheté deux boîtes de 50 masques
des cours n'a vu que ça commence à
chauffer pour les patients parce que moi
je refusais cette année là la doctrine
sur les masques à la changer
lorsque vous reprenez la société
française d'hygiène hospitalière et ce
qu'elle a dit en date du 28 janvier
ça a été repris sur le site de la dgs
guide méthodologique kovy 19 version du
20 février 2009 et c'est resté sur le
site jusqu'à ce qu'un jour je le dénonce
au cabinet
du ministre nous a écouté au moins ayez
la décence de mettre à jour votre site
de la dgs et sur ça on dit clairement
que pour les soignants il faut des ff
les deux c'est très clair alors après on
m'a dit non mais bon comme on n'a pas de
ffp 2 on va mettre un chirurgicale un
double masque chirurgical c'est-à-dire
un match amical pour le soigner et un
match amical pour le soigneur on n'avait
même pas de ma chirurgicaux pour les
soignants n'ont rien comme on a été
équipée donc oui c'est normal connaît un
petit stock mais à partir du moment où
on est dans une situation de crise dont
on parle et c'est la responsabilité de
l'état
je suis désolé ou alors il faut qu'on
rentre dans une logique où chacun doit
avoir des stocks importants mais ça
repose le problème du financement
et ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure on n'a pas du
tout d'accompagnement financier pour ça
donc ça je pense qu'il faut être clair
je pense qu'on peut pas demander à
chaque minimes médical d'avoir des des
cartons entiers de masques je pense que
c'est clairement la responsabilité
d'état deuxième réponse que je voulais
faire sur les organisations de terrain
par rapport aux ars est ce que laissait
pittet c'est le bon niveau écoutez je
crois que c'est un enseignement à tirer
de cette crise c'est qu'on voit bien
qu'il ya des possibilités d'organisation
sur le terrain qui sont diverses et
variées moi je suis opposé à la cpps
voie obligatoire partout et modèle
unique
je pense que la 6 pts c'est un outil qui
est intéressant un certain nombre de
médecins l'ont pris en main ça marche
bien
quelquefois ça dysfonctionne il ya
d'autres outils qui permettent la
coordination des acteurs sur le terrain
ils sont multiples n'oublions pas que il
ya des cabinets médicaux pluri
professionnelle qui sont pas forcément
déclarer en msp qui existe depuis des
années et où les gens travaillent
ensemble parce que c'est pas parce qu ni
sous un même toit qu'on travaille
ensemble et à linverse on peut
travailler ensemble sans être forcément
sous un même toit avec
l'outil numérique on allait si vite et
sont allés maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle en a maintenant les
équipes de soins primaires
on a les équipes de soins spécialisés si
on peut quand même éviter d'avoir des
structures trop bureaucratique
on est des médecins libéraux lice sont
les médecins et les autres celles de
santé s'organiser sur le terrain et sur
la liaison ville hôpital
je pense que là aussi la grosse erreur
c'est d'avoir fait des groupements
spitalier de territoires qui sont des
gros monstres dirigé par un hôpital de
référence qui est censé faire un projet
territorial de santé dans lequel vous
avez pas l'hospitalisation privée et
dans lequel vous avez parti libéral donc
on voit bien qu'on a pensé notre système
de santé oms le centrant sur les
structures et sur l'hôpital et c'est
précisément l'un vers ce qu'il faudrait
faire et je pense que il faut que la
médecine ville se coordonnent s'organise
on a besoin de moyens pour avoir des
outils quelqu'un parler des outils tout
à l'heure on voit bien qu'il ya des
outils qui émerge ici ou là en
particulier avec lee santé de numérique
il faut accompagner ça et ça permettra
de mieux se coordonner et de se
coordonner aussi avec l'hôpital à
l'échelon des territoires ici dans les
territoires il faut vraiment redonné la
main aux responsabilités territoriales
moi je suis un peu inquiet quand je vois
ces j'ai acheté parce que les j'ai
acheté sondés des grosses structures qui
ont tendance à tout régenter dans les
territoires et on a du mal à être en
liaison avec ses grosses structures qui
de toute façon on est exclu une grande
partie de l'offre de soins dans le pays
pour répondre à ces bts nous on n'a pas
de cpt dans le territoire on a
fonctionné très bien avec les
infirmières libérales et des pharmaciens
on organise un centre qu'ovide ça ça a
marché
ça marchait très bien avec le couple
médecins généralistes infirmières et
pour la distribution des masques
on avait un système qui était comparable
à celui de distri masque du grand est où
on avait les les masques on les a eus
tard mais mais avec le le pharmacien ça
marchait ça marche est remarquablement
bien donc je pense qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'une organisation territoriale formelle
mais si on peut se débrouiller avec les
infirmières libérales aider les médecins
et les pharmaciens on assiste aux
structures de base qui marche parce que
ce qui est laid les médecins ils ont été
vite en situation de responsabilité ils
se sont organisés
alors c'est dommage il est parti sur la
formation sur les sur les sur les
pandémies et on a connu la pandémie 2005
et moi les masques ffp2 j'ai quand j'ai
ouvert la boîte de masques ffp2 j'ai eu
la surprise de voir que c'était pas une
lettre de roselyne bachelot mais c'était
une lettre de xavier bertrand donc sur
la dette 2005 avait trente masques ffp2
qui datait de 2005 et est donc là on
peut on avait cette organisation vous
savez c'était au temps de la grippe
aviaire et il y avait tout était écrit
qu il y avait même il était même prévu
que les
les pharmacies ayant des stocks de
tamiflu soit protéger militairement
tamiflu que jamais rester en vie à rien
du tout et est protégé me faire prendre
fin mais c'est qui les détenait donc si
vous voulez et c'était les agents
municipaux habillés comme des martiens
qui distribuait les repas aux patients
qui est aux français qu'ils étaient
confinés chez eux
on arrêtait les écoles on arrêtait les
transports toutes étaient toutes été
arrêtées
c'était ça 2005 la grippe aviaire 1
cette organisation là elle existe donc
on est on n'a pas une formation pendant
vos études mais on a eu quelques
expériences et puis on a eu la grippe
h1n1 avec vous tous qui sait tout ce qui
s'est produit
donc en ce qui concerne au rivotril ça a
été particulièrement choquant de voir qu
on ait eu le droit de prescrire un
médicament qui n'est pas très souple
comme le midazolam pour pour les fins de
vie alors qu'on est toujours interdit de
prescrire du rivotril dans les
acouphènes je vous le rappelle on n'a
pas le droit de prescrire le rivotril en
gouttes dans les acouphènes
de la même façon sur la ventoline ya des
interdictions de prescription pour les
médecins généralistes pour vous dire
qu'elles sont particulièrement mal vécue
par les médecins généralistes sur le
terrain c'est insupportable 1 ne pas
pouvoir prescrire des aérosols de
ventoline etc c'est dingue mais pas
pouvoir prescrire des gouttes de
rivotril c'est absolument scandaleux bon
beaucoup de choses ont été dites sur la
doctrine 2013 donc nul n'est censé
ignorer la loi
le problème c'est que tout le monde de
décret et d'arrêté de loi d'avis qu' on
n'est pas nécessairement au courant et
c'est vrai que le fait que l'employeur
est responsable de la santé de ses
salariés on le savait mais sur les
équipements c'était quand même quelque
chose difficilement prévisibles les
seuls aujourd'hui en médecine
ambulatoire qui avait des stocks de
masques étaient les chirurgicaux qui
travaillait sous anesthésie locale qui
sont équipés chez eux donc avec des
masques jampel quand même que pour le la
distribution des masques donc les
réseaux pharmaceutique était tout à fait
indiquée mais on a bien vu aussi que
même les personnels des cabinets
médicale les personnels des pharmacies
n'était pas inclus dans la distribution
de masques et ça a posé quand même
certains problèmes aussi puisqu'on leur
donner nos propres masques pour se
protéger
le bon niveau c'est pts bon bon niveau
donc je suis un petit peu
je vais préciser un petit peu donc
l'équipe de soins primaires alors la
cpds c'est vrai c'est un niveau
populationnelle voilà ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'en france entre le
ministère et le médecin il ya 16 strates
d'organisation ça fait peut-être un
petit peu beaucoup
et donc à partir de là le s p la cpt s
en serait encore une donc
populationnelle mais la base la base
c'est ce qu'il ya autour du patient donc
on parle des équipes de soins primaires
mais bon il ya plusieurs définitions
l'équipe de soins primaires on n'est pas
tous d'accord là-dessus à l'équipe de
soins primaires à c'est un petit peu
technique l'équipe de soins primaires
qui dépend d'une de formalisation où on
est obligé de passer par une
formalisation autour du patient entre
les acteurs et il ya les équipes de
soins ouverte qui devrait qui pourrait
se constituer sur une formulation
beaucoup plus simple au niveau du dmp
enfin voilà c'est ce qu'on porte au
niveau du syndicat des médecins libéraux
quelque chose de simple qui marche et
qui se faire rapidement sans une
autorisation une administration des
réunions sur l'essai pts a failli
laisser pts pour arriver à monter une
cpts est arrivé à la lettre d'intention
il faut quasiment un an huit mois un an
deux réunions donc il ya quand même
quelque chose qui va paul ensuite donc
sur le décret de de monsieur vers en bas
il s'est peut-être un petit peu
précipité puisque une semaine après le
lancer est revenu sur ses dires donc le
décret a été pris 4,5 jours après je
crois l'apparition c'était très rapide
et est donc comment voyez très
rapidement et une semaine dix jours
après les danses est revenu en arrière
donc d'en cas d'école et ensuite donc
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas parlé des
sondages et compagnie nous on a fait
quelques petits sondages mais bon on est
quand même limité on sondages
maintenant pour pour faire une
conclusion quand on voit sur les pays
pays d'asie où vous êtes quand même
assez spécialisés on voit quand même que
la pandémie en asie n'a pas été aussi
forte qu'en europe parce qu'ils ont des
habitudes qui sont différentes parce
qu'ils ont ils avaient des masques
moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis à bali et ben
s'ils avaient des masques
tout le monde avait des masques voilà
ils ont pas eu de problème pour avoir
des masques
hum voilà et c'est vrai que c'est quand
même assez intriguant qu'en france 5e ce
soi disant pays mondial on n'est pas de
masque pour se protéger
merci beaucoup je vous remercie pour
cette audition terminée voilà pour
l'audition conjointe des médecins
libéraux qui sont revenus sur la manière
dont il avait tenté de faire face à la
crise sanitaire
déplorant notamment le manque de moyens
et de matériel mis à leur disposition
pour leur protection ainsi que celle de
leurs patients
cette audition est à retrouver sur notre
site lcp point fr